[Music]
welcome everyone to streaming the galaxy
my name is rocket riley and today we're
gonna be going over everything you need
to know before watching hawkeye but
before we get started if you're new to
the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified whenever we upload a new video
also there may be spoilers ahead from
some of the other mcu titles along with
some theories which might spoil the tv
show if i'm right
now hawkeye is going to be the newest
phase 4 installment of the mcu franchise
following the release of shang chi and
the eternals the fifth television series
in the mcu this show will follow jeremy
renner as clint barton or hawkeye who
was last seen in avengers end game and
then given as a target to yelena belova
at the end of black widow we'll see him
teaming up and potentially passing on
the hawkeye name to another well-known
archer from the marvel comics kate
bishop who will be played by haley
steinfield haley steinfield is known for
her appearance as charlie in 2018's
bumblebee and as maddie ross in 2010's
true grit
just in time for the holiday season this
series will debut on november 24th with
one new episode following each week
there will be a total of six episodes
each of which will likely be similar in
length to loki and wandavision
this show will take place after the
events of avengers endgame placing clint
in the position of needing to remedy the
destruction he caused as the dark figure
ronan but also wanting to be with his
family after losing them for five years
as a recap hawkeye first appeared in
thor as a shield agent guarding thor's
hammer mjolnir from a watchtower he then
reprised his role in the avengers being
mind controlled by the movie's
antagonist loki by the end of the film
however he rejoined the avengers in the
battle of new york
in avengers age of ultron hawkeye again
fought with the avengers against ultron
and sokovia having his life saved by
wanda maximoff's brother pietro or
quicksilver
after this he retired moving to an
isolated farm with his wife laura and
his children
in captain america civil war however
steve called on clint for help so he
joined cap and his allies at the battle
in germany
absent from avengers infinity war we
next see hawkeye at the beginning of
avengers end game losing his family in a
heartbreaking sequence to thanos snap
later in the film we see clint taking
out villains mercilessly as the
vigilante known as ronan he is pulled
back into the avengers shenanigans
traveling through time and space to
retrieve the soul stone one of the
infinity stones thanos used to wipe out
half of all life in the universe
after losing his close friend natasha
romanoff and their endeavor to get the
soul stone all life is snapped back into
existence and clint receives a call from
his wife
we can only assume from here that clint
goes back into retirement to live with
his family on the farm but my guess is
that his dark past will likely come back
to haunt him as we see that he's placed
as yelena beloveda's target in black
widow there will likely be several
appearances from people who clint
affected during his time as ronan
in addition we see that most of the
story takes place in new york city so we
can guess that yelena or some of her
associates may make appearances in the
show in an effort to eliminate their
target but clint will have kate bishop
on his side to help with any threats
which may arise
now let's get into the backstory of the
other protagonists of this christmas
themed series kate bishop kate bishop
first appeared in the comic young
avengers as an individual with
extraordinary skill in hand-to-hand
combat and with a bow and arrow in the
comics she takes an apprentice-like role
under hawkeye and when he dies she takes
on the mantle of the hawkeye name
although it isn't likely to follow this
exact same sequence of events this show
may feature the beginning of the young
avengers or kate bishop taking on the
code name of hawkeye it'll be exciting
to see how the comic stories differ from
the ones we see on the screen in
november and how clint and katie will
interact with each other
also from the recently released trailer
we see posters and a scene from rogers
the musical i can't wait to see the
avengers battle of new york in musical
fashion and how it plays into the show's
story well that's everything we know so
far and everything you need to know
before watching hawkeye when it's
released later this year if you enjoyed
today's video please consider dropping a
like and if you have any ideas that
you'd like to share for future videos
please drop them in the comments section
below also don't forget to subscribe for
more great content
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
you